yes yes yeah thank you very very nice
nice control yourselves there's only one
of me
but thanks for being here tonight
because we're about to have a difficult
conversation well if I had a dollar for
every time I heard that from my
urologist
hopefully this
so first let's say this
warning what you're about to hear is a
serious topic if you don't think you can
joke about a serious story We suggest
you consider spending the next 15
minutes doing some macrame a few sets of
sit-ups or reading an online brochure
about time shares but if you can handle
a tough subject with a few jokes
sprinkled in then we've got a good one
for you all right well I'm glad you guys
all stayed
now I need to start out by pointing out
that Russell Brand and I are friends do
I know him well no when I lived in
London I knew of him his reputation was
as well known as Winston Churchill Benny
Hill and tooth decay
there was a time when we hated each
other
Greg Garfield vibrates as a human being
in hatred creates a bit of a swine and a
bit of a snide you're a silly sausage
you're stealing oxygen and you're
wasting time your name your weird facial
orifice looks looks like a caving in
anus and most importantly you'll use
your espousing of hatred your emptiness
your the echoing tub of your mind this
does not look like an anus
but gradually that changed he's been on
the show we've talked we've corresponded
hell we even swapped skin care tips
so today yes I'd say we're friends and
I'm not walking away from that
because it's easy to be a friend when
times are good
[Laughter]
patience and refraining from trying
someone in the court of public opinion
because that's part of this story if
you're sitting where I am you know on a
pile of money you have to ask how do we
report on this story accurately how do
we do it justice and I mean actual
Justice not social justice how do we
avoid trial by Twitter which is now
called X how do we assess these
allegations since the law has never been
asked to investigate them until now you
see what I'm getting at the media is
comparing bran to Harvey Weinstein
because both stories were doggedly
reported first by journalists but you
never should make a comparison based on
one variable it's like saying Tom Brady
and OJ are the same because they both
played football or comparing Hillary
Clinton to Jack the Ripper just because
they murdered people
foreign
but you see how it works that's not
reporting that's bomb throwing and it's
just more proof that we live in an era
when investigative reporting is dried up
like airplane glue on the inside of
Hunter's nostrils
speak of the devil did we see this kind
of meticulous search for sources and
stories involving hunter or the steel
dossier Epstein's Client List or pretty
much any story these days yet we now see
some of the most thorough journalism in
memory all this energy devoted to a guy
named Russell Brand not Justin Trudeau
or Joe Biden or Bill Clinton and
Clinton's charity seems shadier than
Brian stelter's feat
because you know he's never over yeah
shade
and of course it happens now not a
decade ago when the events were
allegedly occurring and I get it people
have their reasons for waiting but the
timing is impeccable and I reject
conspiracies but it seems the most
persuasive critics of those in power are
in the crosshairs literally if you're
RFK Junior
I wonder if Brad had lurched left
instead of right would this have become
a story over in England it began with
reporters suddenly searching high and
low for accusers against brand there are
four accusers who have not been
identified publicly and and won alleged
rape none went to the cops then the
producers had an actress portray one
victim in an interview replete with
dramatic background music the story went
viral of course
but Rose McGowan the founder of the
metoo movement has now stepped up to
raise an objection
this is a concerted effort to bend
journalistic rules that have always been
in place such as having to be on the
record with who you are and what your
name is in order to accuse I didn't make
these rules these are the rules they
were the rules so there's something very
strange going on you have to go on the
record it has always been that way I
didn't make it so it didn't make me
happy to have to do so neither did it
make others happy to have to do so but
to blindly
and anonymously accuse
none of these high-level journalistic
Outlets
would have ever let this be published
before so I have to ask why why now what
is a true narrative they're pushing
that took guts which are rare in
Hollywood than an original idea but look
people don't go to the cops for their
own reasons and one big reason will
always be What's called the gray area
the difficult to pin down region known
as the provable facts cops hate gray
areas but the media loves them more than
Joe Biden loves a freshly shampooed
child
for gray areas give them narrative
Freedom they can do what they want like
stories like those celebrating Brands
over the top promiscuity for instance
which for years they found to be just
hilarious and certainly not worth
investigating further everyone claims
his behavior was an Open Secret which is
odd because if it's out in the open it's
not a secret
but at the same time one woman states
she went to a rape crisis clinic after
her encounter with brand it's being
reported as corroborated
so where is the truth I don't know but
that's not the point neither do the rest
of us see we don't need to come to
conclusions now we don't need to condemn
brand and we don't need to condemn the
accusers because the presumption of
innocence should be taken as seriously
as the accusations
and the ultimate way to do that you try
these cases in a real Court not the
court of public opinion because that
court has ruined more lives than drugs
and alcohol combined
look to State the obvious I'm not
Russell Brand I'm not even an off-brand
I'm way too short and homely to have
been a womanizer
most of the sex I had was because I was
a roadie for kajagugu
underrated band
like anyone in the public eye there's
always the chance that knives will come
out thankfully I've only ever paid
foreign hookers to stop peeing on me
should be about learning and following
the facts because sure we had Harvey
Weinstein and R Kelly but we also had
Kevin Spacey Johnny Depp and the Duke
lacrosse team
so let's just remember how many times
the media gets it wrong and you know
what maybe I have two but at least I'm
willing to acknowledge that and wait for
the truth
let's welcome
tonight's guests
mayor Adams wants to use his act to
discourage migrants from coming to NYC
writer and comedian Joe DeVito
thank you
she switched from being a lawyer to
being a comedian to get more respect
comedian Jocelyn Gia
when she sees red hide under your bed
New York Times bestselling author and
Fox News contributor Kat Tiff
and he's volunteered to be the border
wall New York Times best-selling author
comedian and former NWA world champion
Tyrus
yo Tyrus with stories like these
everybody's walking on eggshells which
for you is physically impossible
but you always nail the truth to these
stories how do you see this well I
always look first everyone has the right
to be heard and we always need to
remember that but when we say that we
mean everyone
not the accuser the the man being
accused in this in this situation
does it look bad when you have numbers
come forward a thousand percent but uh
my advice is I when you go through
something like this your life has
changed forever whether you did it or
didn't do it you can win in court but to
the social media World social justice
word the facts are irrelevant it's
feelings or if you don't agree with them
you absolutely had to do it so one of
the things that whenever a man is
accused of something like this
there's this need to go out and explain
yourself
to the media and I think that's the
worst thing you can do if you're
innocent I think as a man if in because
I'm saying man because most of the time
it's us who are confu accused of these
things so
you don't talk to the media because the
only people you really need to be good
with is your family your friends and
your job those are the people that know
if you're willing if they're willing to
stand by you and support you going on TV
and explaining yourself just feeds the
fire to what you were talking about the
reason why they don't want to wait is to
find out the facts and see what happens
because there's no money in it they have
to condemn now they have to get him run
out now they have to make him out to be
this horrible thing now so we'll all
tune in and watch they don't care what
his life is after let me tell you this
is a person who has been
in a similar situation to an accusation
against you your life has changed
forever nothing's ever the same nothing
what would be the same for us if he has
his money in savings let your lawyers
talk for you win in court and if you
have the ability to to go away go away
because it doesn't matter what you do or
say if you did it hit him with every law
that you need to be if you did it if you
sexually harassed somebody if you did
something horrible if you tried to take
someone's dignity away but physically
sexually assaulting them then you should
get hit doesn't matter how long the time
has been a thousand percent but for the
who didn't do it because you talked
about it in your monologue which was
just elegant and perfect is that the
trial by social media facts have nothing
to do with anything no matter what you
do no matter what you prove no matter
what dismissal no matter what apology
there's always going to be somebody on a
keyboard that's going to bring it up and
throw it in your face there's always
going to be somebody there and that's
the thing there's no winners for this
your life will never be the same he will
never be the same doesn't matter what he
does so I my advice if he would ever
listen to me would be stop talking to
the Press don't do interviews be right
with your family your company and your
lawyers don't talk to them because if
you feed the zoo you're going to get the
zoo because that's all they want right
now you know Jocelyn what a great topic
for your first time on the show
planned it I planned it for you you know
why because you used to be a lawyer and
I'm interested as a lawyer slash
comedian
um do you have any do you have any
issues with the anonymity or the timing
or anything
the anonymity well look it's a very
persuasively persuasively written story
I think we have to remember this a story
is not a sign affidavit yeah and and
there were no names which means
you can't have a
Anonymous witness in court right so this
is within a standing court The Only Name
person in the story that I read was a
male comedian saying that he had heard
rumors about these allegations now that
wouldn't fly as evidence in a courtroom
because they'll be hearsay or lack of
personal information so it's beautifully
written as this story is
I I can't say as a lawyer like yeah
castrate him yeah now on the side of the
press though they would have had gone
through some legal checks and balances
to have some corroborating evidence else
they're going to be hit with a
defamation lawsuit from Russell so there
have been some checks and balances done
good point right so I am inclined to be
that there must be something here that
gave them the balls to do this
um but before all is said and done in a
courtroom with Witnesses and testimonial
under oath yeah I wouldn't pass judgment
on him so quickly well put you know cat
the YouTube suspended his uh Channel BBC
pulled his shows uh Paramount plus
removed his comedy special this is
before any anything's been proven guilty
what do you think yeah I like I mean you
guys both had great points a lot of that
I agree with
um I think also that is interesting
right especially because it's been right
a matter of days really to have all that
happen and what I thought was even
really the nuts thing was that Rumble
actually heard from Parliament saying
hey you gotta take you should you got to
take this guy's stuff down and you know
you gotta demonetize de-platform this
guy and I know that like thankfully we
don't do things the way here that they
do in the UK yeah but that's just crazy
to have the government saying hey you
person should go to even put pressure on
that that should be completely you know
up to the platform whether they want to
do that or not and again the fact that
this all happened and in just a matter
of days and rather than wait people just
want to like okay I gotta have the
hottest most fiery take on this you
don't always there isn't always a hot
fiery take on everything and you don't
always need to do that when you said
Parliament I thought of the cigarette
company yeah but it's actually that
weird organization in England that what
that wears the wigs and they have that
big giant clock
you know I never was really good with
history
uh what do you make of this well
comedian or are you claimed to be I do
and I I'm not a I was not a lawyer so I
won't use legal terms like balls
the advice I would give him now is maybe
you don't dress like a cult leader for a
while chill it out a little bit but in a
case like this
um I'll say three words let's find out
yeah let's find out we don't need to to
jump to any conclusions we don't need to
disrespect anybody and I think the
problem we have that as you say to the
average person about any issue what do
you think they don't think what they
tell you is what is the reality I would
like that most fits with what I want to
believe and we see how that every issue
splits yeah in half now that people say
it's the same as if you say to somebody
there was a traffic stop there are
people going to say the cops are no good
and they're people going to say the cops
have a tough job and neither of them has
seen what happened so the reason why we
don't try things in the court of public
opinion is because the public tends to
be angry morons yeah this is why we
don't settle things by pitchforks and
torches and we don't do lynching and
witch burning any more we settle things
in the court of law now as far as the
women not wanting to come out and and
say would have happened that sometimes
it takes years it's because that
requires a great deal of Bravery now
what can we do
being brave is hard yeah maybe we can
make that easier for people to come
forward but I read what they said what
was in the article if it's true it's a
terrible thing and if it's not true
that's also pretty bad yeah so I'll say
it again let's find out there you go
just real quick yeah
Russell Russell Brand financially can
survive this yeah but if you're not
Russell Brand your career is gone right
yeah you can't pay your bills you can't
get a job and let's say a year from now
this comes out that it was all made up
do you think they're going to give them
his jobs back and his shows back no no
well you're free you you made it man
Backpage you're not going to have a
whole special clearing his name they'll
just move on to the next story there's
no consequences if it is true then you
know he should be done thousand percent
but that's the ugliness of the cancel
culture is they win because by the time
it comes around to find out the truth
we've already moved on to the next story
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else